welcome to this video and playing this
guy again right after the came before ok
it's doing something else now Kings
Indian okay
maybe go for the humbucker already don't
know I have played him a number of times
with a great score 9 wins 2 losses I
don't really know what kind of openings
we played ok mmm do I play f3 here or
mmm this may be 94 okay I want to play
Bishop d12 here to see to at some point
and I wasn't sure when to do it so I'm
going to do it now
hmm I'm not sure what is counted layers
okay of course he has the the very
standard looking count to play on the on
the kingside but quite often in this
this type of positions it's also
connected with c6 opening the C file but
this is not really happening with the
bishop on d7 as I can probably just take
one c6 exposing the d6 fine okay Michael
Bishop c2
briefly I'm thinking about night before
looks a bit a bit strange but at the
moment the night on a success is really
a very useless piece
I can't even consider g4u night f-4s the
typical point sacrifice but nothing that
is particularly great and this in this
position I believe okay let's do it he
will probably play it anyway as Knight
f6 looks totally silly this is no
compensation whatsoever
he's got this bishop opened but but what
exactly is the play yeah that you can do
you can but isn't this opening up blacks
King even more than this White's King
Bishop c2a is good night before
maybe maybe with night before
I can awaken lots of castles short come
on
I really don't believe this one bit the
sacrifice
yeah and Bishop c2 night before is a
very very annoying thing otherwise it
would be very nice for me to get this
bishop right on this long diagonal okay
I need to take with the knight
centralizing
and now Bishop c2 is really really in
the mix
okay I can first play Bishop C - why us
why do I need to need to defend this
this rook
okay I don't want to give it up just yet
you should see to King AJ I'm not sure
that that it helps me very much oops
what's this I didn't think about that at
all okay man let's take it I see him I
seem
I hope she ate maybe I still have this
right that's very very fortunate Bishop
takes a knight f6 with a double check
I always have checks in my G through
check for example queen g 7i g 3 chicken
with 95 double check looks spectacular
but he just knows the king it's not
clear what I have gained I'm a
threatening something here and I'd have
6 problem King G 6 King G 7 night h5
chicken maybe I'm threatening that the
96 I'm definitely threatening and then
taking the bishop
OOP G a check
I guess really night g3s the simplest
isn't this 96 check No
might take C - bauru p-51 Knight f6 s
this is a double check IAM check double
check it should be check should be quite
strong time Barney okay I can take h6 no
I guess just take age six or it says
something something better it's not
threatening the Queen really let's see
seven hangs
don't see a major it's a new
I simply didn't see a maid trying for up
to one but he has got checkmate got
dismayed ah what an idiotic game again
every a sometimes I play like a total
[ __ ] I mean I mean certainly rusty from
the from the three weeks off but not
winning this I mean better stop playing
chess at all
I mean totally totally over this stuff
check how do we know
Bishop g6 is the simplest just moving
this yeah I saw that I mean the the
Queen is not hanging I have a pin here
but I wanted to they want it to mate him
yeah campus should be officially for
also wins this is not winning yeah now
over let me made it one even yeah I was
really irritated very strange check and
well I'm not great in this kind of this
kind of irrational positions anyway I
mean at least with limited time but yeah
this is a bit heartbreaking to lose this
after black is basically committing
suicide not this is simply not working
at all I mean black is probably in bad
shape in any case but this is some
really quite clearly quite clearly
choosing okay thanks for watching